well what we know about the vaccination
program is this is a global problem
and we need a global solution and we're
only going to be able to deal with this
disease
if we get everybody vaccinated across
the world so it's vital we work together
it's vital we keep borders open and we
resist
vaccine nationalism and we resist
protectionism and i've been working with
my fellow trade ministers to make that
happen
we're pleased that the eu admitted that
the article 16
invocation which you talked about for
the border in ireland has been
uh was a mistake and they have
they are now not proceeding with that
but fundamentally the way we're going to
get through this crisis
is working together and i'm very pleased
that the uk is leading the way
uh we've got the fantastic vaccine task
force under kate bingham
which now has seven vaccines on order
367 million doses of those vaccines
and we know that that supply is secure
uh we're absolutely confident we can
continue to deliver our program
we have received reassurance from the
european union
that those contracts won't be disrupted
but now i think we need to move forward
work together with our counterparts
across this world rather than putting in
restrictions and protectionism which
ultimately will only damage citizens
you say that you've got had reassurances
from the eu
that our vaccine supply won't be
affected but this really matters doesn't
it because
a lot of people will be looking at this
and they will be alarmed about whether
or not
um the vaccines that they have already
been given
the fires one in particular if they'll
be able to get a second dose
uh if the vaccines in the uk will be
impacted
exactly what reassurances have you been
given on that
well the prime minister has spoken to
ursula van der leyen
she has been very clear that those
contractual supplies
won't be disrupted that's a very
important assurance of course we
also have our uk produced vaccines
as well and you know if you look at our
vaccine pipeline
367 million doses we have
a significant supply to be able to
vaccinate the uk population
specifically specifically can you
guarantee that everyone who's had the
first dose
of the fisa vaccine will get their
second dose they won't be given another
vaccine we we can absolutely guarantee
our programme of delivery of the vaccine
and
we have received assurances from the eu
about the supply
under contract of all of those vaccines
okay now you've talked a lot about the
fact that you resist protectionism
on the vaccines michael gove said
yesterday that our first priority is
vaccinating people in the united kingdom
but we also want to work with our
friends and neighbours in the european
union in order to help them
as well i mean that all sounds quite
noble but what does it mean does that
mean that
once we've vaccinated the most
vulnerable in the uk we might look at
giving vaccines to other countries the
uk has led in terms of things like the
kovacs programme
we've created the oxford vaccine which
is a relatively low cost easy to deploy
vaccine
could we can be very supplies to other
european countries
well of course we first need to make
sure that our population is
vaccinated we have a target to get the
most vulnerable
vaccinated by mid-february it's a bit
too early to say about how we would
deploy
xx vaccine but we certainly want to work
with friends and neighbours
we want to work with developing
countries because we're only going to
solve
this issue once everybody in the world
is vaccinated and
we're also working to keep trade flowing
which is really important
keep tariffs low or eliminated on
medical goods and supplies
so that we can make sure that all the
world benefits
from the expertise here in the united
kingdom i think everyone could
understand that you know if we have an
oversupply vaccine then it does make
sense to
help other countries who may not have
the same amount but at what point does
that happen
does that happen once we've vaccinated
all the
vulnerable by mid-february as we hope
does that happen when we've vaccinated
all the over 50s
the entire population when do we start
thinking about that
we're sticking by our vaccination
timetable which is of course making sure
the most vulnerable
are vaccinated by mid-february that we
complete the
the first nine groups by the spring and
all adults by the autumn so that
program will happen and of course
some of these supplies you know that
there have been supply issues so we need
to make sure that the new drugs that are
coming online
are dela you know are delivered the
population is vaccinated but of course
as we're developing that we are also
working with other countries
about how we can help because this it
won't benefit people in britain if we
become a vaccinated island and
many other countries don't have the
vaccine because
virus will continue to spread so we need
to tackle this on a
global way um prioritization at that
point
would we prioritize um some of our
closest
neighbours and allies places like
ireland for example would
would we prioritize developing countries
who many of them who've whom not
vaccinated anybody so far
well the uk's presidency of the g7 this
year is a vital opportunity for us to
lead on this to work with our g7
partners but also work with developing
nations who
need need the vaccine to make sure their
populations are protected as well and i
don't think it's in either all
you know capacity is being ramped up
across the world in terms of these
vaccine
production and i think by working
together
we can deal with this problem much
better than by working alone and putting
up
unnecessary restrictions okay um the
government had a target
to vaccinate the first to give a
perspective dose
to all care home residents and staff by
the end of january i mean today's the
31st so how's that target been met
we have vaccinated over 8 million people
i'm sure we'll have the full report by
the end of today but we're certainly
uh on track to make sure we hit that
target
specifically on care homes are we on
track to have met the target to
vaccinated
all residents and staff in care homes by
the end of today
we are on track but we'll get the full
report so v
once once today is over we'll be able to
report next week and the health
secretary
will give an update in the house so so
we're not sure yet we haven't got the
full data through is that what you're
saying
well of course we haven't because it's
the 31st but as i say the health
secretary will give an update to the
house and i'm sure
there will be positive news okay sounds
quite confident
in that case um i just want to talk to
you about report in the sunday telegraph
this morning they're saying that spy m
which is the subgroup of sage the
scientists who advise the government has
said
that social distancing could be in place
for the rest of the year
unless vaccines are 85 effective
in reducing transmission now that's a
pretty tall order
is that realistic is that right that
actually we could be looking at social
distancing measures
for the rest of the year what we're
doing is we're putting our shoulders the
wheel making sure we get these vaccines
rolled out
it's very important when people do get
the call that they
take up the vaccine offer what we want
to do is start opening up
things as soon as we are able to whilst
at the still
the same time protecting lives and the
prime minister has said
that all going well we'll be able to
open up our schools from
the 8th of march i don't want to make
predictions about the situation in the
autumn
i think it's far too far away but we
have to take this on a step-by-step
basis
opening up as we're able making sure the
most vulnerable are protected
and that's the way to deal with this
issue i think long-term predictions
in what is a very very unpredictable
situation and not are not wise
is that spy m report correct though
well i mean it's a it's a long-term
prediction and what i've just said is we
need to take this on a
week by week basis as we monitor what
happens to the disease
and the way to solve this is through
global cooperation it's through making
sure that we roll out the vaccine
program
in the way we have been doing it's
making sure people are complying with
the rules and that's what will help us
get through this i think speculating
about what's going to happen
in the autumn is far too far away
of course one of the things one of the
reasons we can't predict
how things are going to go is because we
don't know what's going to happen with
new variants
uh how they're going to react to the
vaccine and how they're going to react
to you know the population as well
so how many cases of the south african
variant
and the brazilian variant are currently
in the uk
well i i don't have figures for how many
variants are in the uk
what we do know is the vaccines that we
have
either deployed or are on order are
doing a good job of dealing
uh with those variants and we have some
very highly qualified scientists and
doctors
making sure that our vaccine program
is not just dealing with the original
variant of covid but also
looking at the future variants and
making sure we are
fully protected but i think it's it's
unwise for politicians to
uh try and speculate on the details of
variance in the same way as the future
predictions of the
outbreak of the disease it's difficult
though isn't it um
you know you admit that you don't know
exactly how many cases of these variants
are
in the united kingdom will you say that
of course there is some encouraging news
on the
vaccine efficacy against them but with
many of the vaccines there are frankly
pre-mixed results on it do we think do
you think we're going to look back
and think that not being tougher on our
borders was one of the biggest mistakes
this government made if i look for
example
jeremy hunt called for international
travel to be shot stopped on the 4th of
january we'll hear from him a bit later
at that point there was no known cases
of the brazilian baron in the uk there
are now three times according to matt
hancock as many
cases of the south african variant why
do we not act
tougher sooner on borders we have been
very tough on the borders if you
remember last year we put in place the
travel corridors we've banned travel
from particular countries we put in a
pre-travel
testing regime uh we've tightened things
up further
travel corridors aren't tough are they
they're saying that you can travel to
the uk from other countries
but in every case sophie we are facing a
choice
of how do we deal with something
a virus that is changing we need that
choice wrong on traffic
we need to protect lives and protect
livelihoods and recognize that the uk is
an open economy you know
look at the situation we had with france
at the end of december when we
you know had truckers who had to be
tested for covet you know we have fresh
fruit and vegetables coming in
with truckers and trucks so we need to
make sure
that we are protecting our borders but
at the same time
we do need to make sure that the economy
can continue to run and fresh supplies
can be delivered to the united kingdom
so there is nothing you can expect
that's right they can't you can expect
freight and
there's always a balance to be struck
and you cannot hermetically seal
the uk borders that is not practical i
think what we have taken
is the right measures at the right time
to ensure we are dealing
with the way the virus has developed
one of the big sacrifices of course uh
has been on schools closing schools
you know i can't help thinking as well
um about the big sacrifice so many of
our young people
have made in the last year they've had
their education
so terribly disrupted they haven't been
able to see
their friends very difficult course for
you know young people for teenagers as
well
all this of course for a virus where the
likelihood is that they'll only suffer
very mild
symptoms has the government really done
enough to help
what could be a real mental health
crisis and an education crisis in our
young people
i mean look i know how difficult this is
i have two teenage children at home
who have been you know on zoom classes
for the last few months and
it's tough for them it's tough for
parents we all want
our children to be able to go back to
school to enjoy socialising with their
friends again to get the
in classroom teaching which is so
important to education but ultimately
this is an issue of life and death you
know the school transmission
transmission in the community was
resulting in a spike in coronavirus
cases and leading to death so this has
been
a very very difficult situation you know
what we can do
is make sure the vaccine rollout program
is working as fast as possible
make sure that we are complying with all
the rules
so that we can get those schools back on
march the 8th
yeah i think it's incredibly important
we're obviously doing a lot of work to
make sure that children are able to
catch up
that parents have the right support as
we
leave the lock down and as we recover
the economy after coronavirus but
you know it is really really tough and i
think we're all we're all feeling it
sophie
um some people are saying that we should
move teachers up the vaccination
priority list to try and get schools
uh to reopen that's what tony blair had
told me yesterday we'll hear from him in
a moment he says it might only take a
couple of days to vaccinate teachers
is that something that should be
considered the issue is that for every
person you vaccinate who isn't in the
most vulnerable group that's somebody in
the most vulnerable group who isn't
getting their vaccine
and who is more likely to die in
the next few weeks and months and i i
just don't think that's right and that
is the decision made
by the independent committee that we are
going to vaccinate
first the over 70s and those in the most
vulnerable group
and then the over 50s and i think it's
right that we do have an independent
committee that looks at the priorities
of course we want everybody to be
vaccinated of course we
want the schools to be open but we face
a really difficult choice and
the most important thing is protecting
lives and that is why we've had to
do the vaccine priorities in the way we
had and you know people are working
night and day you know fantastic health
service the vaccine
uh task force working night and day to
get this program so we are maximizing
you know the amount of vaccines we get
out you know there aren't
there isn't spare capacity to vaccinate
other people we do have to prioritize
those who are most vulnerable to dying
that is the
that is the stark truth we face um keen
of course to talk to you
about things other than covid as we come
to the end of the interview uh you're
announcing today that we're going to be
joining the
trans-pacific partnership which is this
trade bloc with countries like australia
japan
at mexico have you done an assessment of
how much this
will boost our gdp well this is a
really fast-growing group of countries
so some countries like mexico malaysia
they're rapidly rising up the global
league tables and what we want to do
is hitch britain to those fast-growing
economies we'll see reduced tariffs from
things like whiskey
cars computer games technology
and that will enable british business to
export more
to those countries and unlike the eu
there aren't the strings attached so we
wouldn't have a court
making judgments we wouldn't have any
control over our borders lost
uh we wouldn't be paying any money in so
this is all about
lowering those barriers so that we can
get more of our fantastic british
products
into those fast-growing markets so for
example in malaysia
currently they're paying over 100
tariffs on whiskey
if we could get those tariffs reduced it
means more exports more opportunities
for the scotch industry in in scotland
um
these things are always difficult to
assess we will produce a scoping study
when we start the formal negotiations
which is likely to be
later on in the spring but fundamentally
what it is about is lowering barriers to
opportunities for british business
without wanting to you know diminish the
importance of signing up to these um
partnerships or trade deals any
assessment is likely to
pale in comparison to the gdp that we
lost
after leaving the single market after
leaving
the european union isn't it i mean the
obr estimates for example that standard
trade deal like the one that we
negotiated would
reduce our gdp by around four percent
compared to the previous relationship
well i don't i don't accept the premise
of that question because all of the
scenarios the uk economy is growing
and we have secured now a brexit deal
well we've secured a brexit deal that is
tariff-free and quota free so now we've
got the best of both worlds
we can trade freely with the european
union and trade freely with these
fast-growing parts of the world
and if you add up cpt bpp and the united
states
that's 40 of global gdp that is a huge
market for us to go after
you know we're the second largest
services expert we haven't got to deal
with it
we haven't got traded with the united
states yet haven't we well we're working
on that as well safely
those are both in the pipeline but my
point is there is these huge
opportunities
out there and those markets are growing
faster
than the eu market so we need to think
about where do we want britain to be in
2030
where do we want us to be in 2050 when
digital trade is much more important
when british products like financial
services and
robotics will be in huge demand across
the world
so what i am doing is laying that
groundwork for our future economic
opportunities
okay liz trust thank you very much for
coming on the program this morning good
to talk
thank you